Eric thank you so much for joining us
we're going to be talking about the
ending and the path that leads to the
ending of God of War Ragnarok so
spoilers if you haven't finished the
game you at home but if you clicked on
this video I assume you already know
um how much of the ending of the game
was kind of locked while God of War 2018
was in development
I don't think any of it was really yeah
I think we when we finished 2018
we started to figure out whether we were
going to do two or three games that was
the first big question once we settled
in two then there was some Stakes put in
the ground about what needed to happen
um and Corey gave me three things he's
like these three things have to happen
after that you figure it out and what
were the three things Ragnarok has to
happen the kids got to leave and Brock's
Gotta Die oh interesting yeah wow but
like the rest of it like the prophecy
because obviously at the end of the tour
of the first game there is that moment
where you see oh
um Kratos is dead and atreus is standing
with Odin was that always kind of like
we know how that's going to resolve or
was it always a case of or was it a case
of them like we'll figure out how we'll
get there there's always multiple
answers and we as we start to figure out
what we want to do next and how we want
to take it even further in the future we
start to pick which ones but there's
it's not as cut and dry as I think
people make it out to be you know I
think it's much like you know if you
probably asked even like somebody like
George RR lightweight do you know like
no once he starts writing the book you
start to see where it's going to go I
don't think he's going to 100 mapped out
all the time I could be wrong I don't
know him I mean he's awesome he's way
better than we are but I think that's
kind of how it goes it's the creativity
part you start to get little pieces that
lead you here or there
um much like Corey said before he's gone
on record you know the kid wasn't Loki
until like almost three years into
development you know I mean those things
sometimes they rise in a good way yeah
but yeah we want to talk briefly about
some of the other characters
yeah we were putting this together like
three yeah okay keep on keep going yeah
so I guess starting point Odin and Thor
like that first scene the where they're
in the house
the tension in the I was trying to
remember what kind of like it reminded
me of but it was closest I came was like
it's like a Tarantino style tension but
you're just like oh these are like gods
that could destroy this plane of
existence it's just like a powder keg
what was it like what was the thinking
behind that moment and what was the kind
of intention behind that moment sure so
I'm in a slightly skip ahead and I'll
come back
um the
final confrontation between Thor and
Odin happens
in Odin's front yard at his house
and so we wanted to have this kind of
echo idea again like balder showed up at
kratos's house and knocks on the door
the order shows up
knocks on the door
Odin shows up knocks on the door you
know Freya shows up in the front yard
and tries to kill him
everybody comes to Curtis's house but we
knew he was going to go to their house
at the end and you do not want Kratos
coming to your house you know what I
mean so it was like this long con for
that bit but also because we wanted to
get them in there early we talked about
these characters a lot in the last game
and he's like no one really wants to
hear about him anymore they want to see
him yeah and so we're like just get them
in there you know and it also was the
narrative purpose of it right that it's
like Odin's trying to talk through this
like hey let's just not do this
you know Kratos being stubborn Kratos
but not really there's more to it he
will not be on the service of any God
ever again it's just not he can't right
that's like a hard rule for him so even
though you're like to just just say yes
and the game's over yeah
Christmas no and then here we go you
know so that was kind of the idea behind
that scene but you're right that
Tarantino influence is there for sure
you know like like we're fans of that
stuff we watch it all and there's so
many influences from so many different
movies
um inside the game because we're
products of that every idea is an
association of all the ideas you've had
up to that point in time when you gel
your idea one thing I loved about the
the kind of thought Odin relationship
was how it's like
obviously you have the creator of the
treas relationship with the Thor and
Odin one just it seemed even more of a
powder keg like every single time Odin
would talk down to him I'd be like is he
gonna snap is this gonna be the time is
it gonna snap what was it like to have
these two very different kind of um
father-son relationships going on at the
same time and how do you balance that
across the whole game yeah again that
was super intentional the the writing
staff
um we really kind of landed on this idea
of like mirrors and clones like that's
kind of a signature I think for the way
that the story is told and it works
because of the One-Shot camera as well
because you have to be there with them
there's no like cut away and you figure
out what's going on you're like you kind
of sit in those moments so they
seep in a lot deeper so when we show you
the cautionary tale or the other side of
the coin or whatever phrasing you want
to use it lands because it's kind of
been built up even though you don't
really know what's happening but it's
been seeding in pretty good
but it's your point about seeing both of
them it was important for that reason
because you if if you don't
know why Thor is the way he is then you
kind of
don't understand why magnet Modi were
the way they are and then why it's
through the way she is and that was like
we wanted to kind of show that as almost
like a do-over right where you
Thor and Sif know they kind of messed up
with the boys like they were still too
young probably to have them and they
weren't good parents and they were
probably still out Rowdy drinking and
having a good time and all this and not
being parents through it's like their
do-over it's like we're gonna do it
right this time you know and that's why
they're protecting her more and you know
but but Thor being Thor's like well
she's got to learn still letting her go
off and do the stuff and Mom's like no
no no we don't want to mess up again and
they don't know where that lies and as a
parent that's hard because no there's no
rule book you know get that and critters
doesn't get a rule book with address
right and he fumbles a bit all
throughout 2018. he fumbles a bit in
this game holding on too tight so that's
the beauty of it is like people can
connect whether you're a child or the
parent or somewhere in between you can
find the story with each of these
characters like from the different
parental units
um and I think that's very telling of
the world we live in that when people do
stop and kind of put their own BS aside
and they look at it it's like everybody
kind of has similar problems and we
should probably be a little bit more
united in these ideas but also it's
super stressful and I can only deal with
my stuff so I can't even have to take
the time to stop and look at what's
going on with you right
yeah I guess was there a kind of
obviously like different people bring
different ideas and themes and that kind
of stuff but was it a particular kind of
theme that you were looking at
um when it comes to Odin and his
relationship with his children and the
other Acer that you were kind of zeroing
and on for me like one of my reads main
reads is like the the manipulative power
that family can have over you when
treated you know if they're kind of like
predisposed to it and it's a something
that I feel like Kratos has in the past
had
um or like struggled with and it's
something that feels like unchecked on
odi's side because there's some this
really powerful thing a figure like Thor
who's like legendary powerful and he's
like brought to his knees by this little
old man who's technically you know
father of them all but still just a man
like an old man so what was the kind of
is there one or is there what was your
interpretation of what you were trying
to go for in it I think what we were
trying to land on at the end of the day
is that
Odin is
not there a lot so anytime he is
everyone wants that attention you can
see it from Heimdall right when he's
there he's like oh I got an audience
with him for this little bit of time and
then he just tells him to leave have you
notice that Odin's always telling people
to leave yeah and he's off to do
something else so if you can get just a
moment with him it's almost like that
far away Prince idea right like and it's
you can't get access to them you can't
there can be no harm done and so
everybody gets time with them and when
they do then they feel special and when
other people then see him spending so
much time with atreus who is new they're
like why is this kid so special and then
everyone's like jealous of that you know
so that was the idea with him is that
he's always moving he's always doing
he's always doing he's super selfish
he's driven by one thing he wants to
know he has to know and if you have
someone like that if you've ever had a
parent or even someone in your family
like that they're not present a lot and
you're always seeking that attention
from them or that approval and that's
really where a lot of the trauma comes
from and then Thor passes that on to his
kids but through a different way through
the physical means because he's physical
in his parenting it's very much like a
felt like a cult leader mentality
whereas like you keep people at a
distance and you only give them a little
bit of your time because if you show
them too much of yourself they start to
find the holes in you who you are and
that undermines you so like I always
felt like ever anyone around Odin had
the power to like usurp him or like
realize something happened and it was so
frustrating seeing this annoying older
man just like pull these strings in this
way so it's like very well done in terms
of writing yeah we took a lot of
inspiration from Amadeus all right oh
you know because you have the main guy
that's always training to do the best
work and then Ahmed issue shows up and
it's just like you know wounded King
just crushes it and he's just like why
you know even I think it's these lines
where he's like why does God choose this
silly vessel to speak through when I'm
here just wanting to do it all and that
was the idea that Odin just needs to
know and he just stayed on it and then
the kid shows up and he's like you can
just translate stuff that he's been
working on for years and he's like he's
like impressed but he's also not happy
about it you know he's playing it
because he wants to keep him close but
he's like Odin's not happy with his kid
being able to do these things that he
can't do for all this time because he's
supposed to be the guy right so even
Odin to your point Invincible do
whatever you want nobody bothers him the
kid gets to him a little bit just a
little crack right and that's what gives
a Trey his power and why he could keep
coming back and do what he did so it's I
I love those little things because you
don't pick up what I'm on length the
first time they're subtle enough but
they're not like hidden enough that
you'll never find it and we like that
kind of Storytelling
um obviously one of the things that the
story hinges on is tear
um the Norse god of war
um referred to many times in the
original game
um and then has a very big part to play
um the reveal of tear not being tear
um when did that come about how
how did you factor that into the story
and how what was the process of making
sure no one clued onto it until it was
the right time oh boy
um this is gonna be the rest of the time
so to start real tier was going to be
real tear in the game and then one day I
came in and I asked writers I was like
What if
tears Odin and they just looked at me
like
what
and I was like yeah what if like this is
the way that he Maneuvers for everything
like that's how he knows everything
that's going on because it's just him
the whole time and then when you said
that I had the the office like shaky
campus yeah
just so someone just take loads of
Post-it notes no and it kind of was like
that and they said okay hey hey let us
go away and I think they went away for
about a week you know five six days or
something like that to put it through
his Paces because they were like this is
interesting this might be the thing that
you know we're not going to get a blades
moment that was 15 years the lead into
that you know
maybe we could pull this off and then it
came back and they're like I think it
can work and then it became this fun
game of like how can we Teeter him on
the line to your point where it doesn't
go over the line but it's just enough
when you go back you're like how did I
see that right like the stuff like him
calling like Freya Freight just yeah
look at her you know this is the one
that I keep mentioning he's like
obsessed with her room yeah I was like
it's because it's a Xbox husband simping
and you see these little things like
even if you go back to where you rescued
him if you go into that chamber there's
Raven feathers in the corner oh there's
all kinds of little stuff like like
dotted throughout the game
um but once we once we got there we're
like okay we're gonna do the the mystery
right we're gonna do the Sixth Sense
thing like where you don't know until
you know again I already told you that
Brock has to die yeah how does he die
and we were like he would figure it out
of all the characters in the game Brock
C's through BS yeah he's the most like
that guy the pragmatic one that's gonna
figure it out so we were like okay
and then the really gnarly thing that
popped up and I can't remember who came
up with this idea but was tears been
cooking for the family the whole time
daddy would kill him with the kitchen
knife oh yeah because he has it on him
you see him over there cutting carrots
and making food for everybody at night
because he wouldn't have a weapon yeah
he doesn't want a weapon the whole game
so he had that thing oh yeah and that's
what he gets him when he gets him with a
kitchen knife it's and it's also like
clue you can play Clue with this yeah
and it's also like very Odin right it's
like this this like sniveling kitchen
knife is how you would do it instead of
like some like massive ax or something
like that yeah but yeah brutal too she
was rough it was rough yeah did you see
it coming at all uh in this you know
that I think it was planned this way
I realized as it started to happen just
like a second before and I was like wait
a second why is things it mentally
freezes you right yeah and that's where
like it clicked into place but then I
didn't have time to like put it through
its Paces in the way that you guys did
and before I could like really reflect
on whether it was a an accurate thought
or not it was over and I was like I've
been red weddings again like oh that's
what we wanted there because it's like a
one-two punch like right you're like
what and then you're in shock of that
and then Brock's there and then they
disappear and you're just like left
holding the bag yeah of every you know
everybody's gone that was part of that
conflict and now you guys have to pick
up the pieces and you can't nobody can
and they go into that grief moment and
then they go back to the house and then
they have the moment with syndrie which
was that was the thing I think a lot of
people didn't see coming we saw this
play test a lot where they were just
like that Arc of syndrome down at the
beginning
and we treated like The Giving Tree
right the whole game he's like here's
your compasses yeah let me fix this and
then by the time you get to that moment
he's just the stump and I love that and
it's never walk back like he's he's
forever changed by that like in at the
funeral which is like a beautiful scene
he's there but you can tell he's still
not over this like he's it's all he's
almost yeah when he just creates that
stare now yeah and you're like yeah
because before he's always getting back
down by Kratos right yeah yeah
completely like no
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid of
anything
yeah and I mean was it I mean I know
Corey kind of gave you those three
things was it always meant to be Brock
and like why did why did he have to die
why did someone have to die
Tori it when he told me that he goes do
you know why and I was like yeah I
remember the conversation we had years
ago in 2018 that Brock was the family
dog that was the inspiration that is
evil man but that's why I'm not happy
enough with Kaylin and wolf at the very
beginning we didn't kill him
like but that's why it's
freaking you know you can kill
characters and you may not care but
that's how life goes you know usually
the person that's close to you is the
one you don't want to lose and when you
do that's What Hurts the Most so and we
you know if you if you brought them back
together we had to break them apart
because again get back to the mirroring
and the cloning if we're going to bring
Kratos and them back together and they
break apart it has to be on a different
set of circumstances yeah like they made
the choice Rock and syndra got no choice
in it
much like water easy yeah
now that I've told you the secret you
could probably write all kinds of kinds
of stuff my prayers are going to hate
yeah that's awesome trick
I mean in terms of another character
who's experiencing or experience loss
and you know she's still very much
processing and I think freya's Ark and
especially where we see him yeah please
we've been building a dining table
afraid I thought Danielle incredible oh
my gosh that's excellent but the uh like
the beginning you know when she's so so
angry I mean you know you're obviously
later on you're talking about how
everyone processed Brock
um how do you approach Freya like this
Mother's grief
I think exactly what you just said is
that like you know there's that old
saying that no parent should have to
outlive their child and I think we
really took that to heart and
um you can't
just I mean what are you going to do
with that um and so
her grief is both that and then there's
still anger she's still very angry at
Odin and everything she gave up and to
try to make it better and it still
didn't work out so that's where a lot of
the Genesis came from like okay
she's almost projecting this onto Kratos
because she can't get to Odin yeah so
what if we could figure out a way to
align them where it was like
I know this I took this from you but
we're really going in the same direction
let's go get this guy
and that's where all of the connections
started to come together for us where
you're like okay but again you have to
earn that and you know It's tricky
because we wanted to get her back soon
but not too soon and for some people
it's two Stills too soon it's it's
almost impossible to like thread that
needle but
I was very happy with the way it kind of
turned out in the end because when you
see that scene when she's ripping out
the roots
um and you know it's starting to unravel
a little bit
um and then they have that conversation
and they shake hands and you're just
like because she still says right there
she's like I don't know she's like she's
almost like a spinning top and you know
if it's going to fall over it keeps
spinning you know and I love that kind
of tension that Daniel brings to it and
specifically that moment when she was
down ripping those roots out and we did
a lot of takes and I went over and the
in the volume there's like this very
like soft carpet you know and it it was
like wet and tears wow she just gives it
every take just going so hard and uh you
know she's can't say anything good
things about Danielle she is Freya I
mean there's yeah that was my favorite
scene in the game and the reason I love
it is because it is the most human
Kratos has also been because you have
that moment where Freya is unraveling
and then you have Kratos be like I
shouldn't have robbed you of that
decision and it's a moment where you can
tell he put that out there not knowing
what was going to come back but hoping
it would be forgiveness and when she
says like she kind of reconciles with
him and walks away the camera lingers
and Kratos for a just a little longer
and you can see the weight kind of go
off of him like he like and I was like
that is just an incredible moment where
this character you can see like the
weight of what he the decision he made
be lifted from him slightly and the
guilt slightly eased and I was like this
is like a jaw-dropping scene of of
acting and writing and delivery it's
amazing that you noticed that last
little bit because I remember talking to
Chris about that specifically that
because we were going to use that linger
and he goes well you know well what is
the motivation here and all that and it
was like
could you have done what she just did
yeah awesome if he was in the opposite
of that could you could you let it go
yeah did you you know he's like and then
that's what makes you stick you know
because you that will run through your
head if someone's able to like give you
that forgiveness like could you give it
back and it's it's a hard thing in life
yeah there's like a shake in his hand as
well and it's like I was just so
impressed by that moment so yeah yeah
the two of them when they're together
it's impressive and that's why I loved
post game yeah that together and like I
was so glad that I saved a bunch of
content like a bunch of side stuff for
them because now you have this different
perspective where they're both like
bouncing off each other and it's so good
to have Freya and papers yeah dunking on
me and it's like
I don't know man I'm like I ship you
guys
but uh let's quickly go through the a
couple of remaining characters atreus
um or just the small ones yeah a couple
of small ones the trails were kind of
wrapping up like yeah yeah yeah who
cares but like obviously like he's in
his teenage phase
um and what was kind of like the
approach for him because there's so much
going on with that one character he's
like trying to figure out who he is he's
going through this like
phase where he thinks he's you know how
almost teenagers are where they're like
I am the be all end-all I have to save
the world and that's where he's at and
then at the same time he meets agraboda
and thrude and what was kind of the arc
that you wanted him to go on
it's you pretty much just said it all
okay it's like that thing as a kid where
it's like you everything feels like the
end of the world or the weight of the
world because your world is Tiny you
know like your world view at like 12 is
nothing you know it's like maybe it's
maybe you've been out of state maybe out
of country if you're lucky you know what
I mean um so like it's small and every
time it gets opened up you change
and I think that's what's funny a lot of
people are like oh why would he make
this decision or why would he do this
like did you not remember it was like to
be 14 years old like come on like people
it's really dumb stuff yeah like even
just like the whole thing of yotenheim
was that idea of like you know it's like
10 p.m's curfew
it's like 10 17.
might as well stay out till 2 A.M at
this point right you know so
um that's that kind of feeling where you
just wanted to put you back in those
shoes is you could look through that and
be like
I probably did dumb things like this but
I'm So Into what he's doing right now
and I want to hang out with these
characters and who's the skilled guy
like yeah I mean like like that was
really just it to make you have that
feeling of being a kid again and I I
know for some God of War fans that's a
leap and it's not everyone's favorite
level but it was very important for
atreus because all the things that
happen after that don't work if you
don't have that moment of just seeing
him be a kid you know what I mean and
just be free you know just to think and
talk and discuss things and uh it's also
expanding his world view and like making
a friend was such a huge thing as adults
yeah yeah it's just the idea of like let
him see something other than what his
dad points at and like being able to see
angrobota and like reconnect with some
of his Heritage and that kind of stuff I
like that that whole thing is for me why
he makes that decision at the end the
way he's like I'm going on my own I've
got stuff to do and it wouldn't happen
unless he had that moment so I feel like
he makes perfect sense it's like the two
of them you know um they uh aren't
together in that cause like just because
he goes up that way and she goes the
other way and you see her back to Johan
at the end it's like they're doing it
together like you know they swap the
marbles
and the marbles are what help they're
almost like compasses that help find
each other when they go through the
utengard and it's like you know she
already had his that's why she keeps
finding him but she gave him Her Marble
you know so they're gonna they're gonna
be a thing if we ever get around to that
in the future we'll see DLC I have no
idea I have no idea what the future
holds at the studio that's about my pay
grade but uh yeah
yeah but I mean even if
I I went back to
um after and you know he kind of gives
her the approval oh yeah I did it's one
of my favorite lines I like you yes I
was like wow that is ridiculous because
it's also you know he in many ways
across the course of the game is
loosening his grasp like he he loves
atreya so much he just wants to protect
him but then he kind of has that moment
where he realizes that he is capable and
he can do it they can do it together but
he is capable he doesn't have to hang on
so tight despite this prophecy that's
been looming over him uh the whole the
whole game and I mean how do you how do
you approach like balancing all of that
like
it's I mean it's super difficult uh
there's so many plates being spun and um
I think it really comes down to like
almost like I'm gonna get this a little
messed up because I haven't said it in a
long time but the kind of like thesis
statement of 2018 was like you know
could a boy teach a monster to be a man
and could
a father
you know teach his son to be a better
God it's something along those lines and
then for this was like you know what
what kind of
in a man would create us be without his
son and what kind of God well trades me
out without his father you know when
because we know they're gonna when they
go back into their old ways would he
become the Loki that we all know in the
myth a super trickster just terrible
kind of thing
in them by you know uniting so much in
this game and teaching each other and
having that promise you know the uh
between them I think that's where we
landed on this idea and then when Chris
had those final lines it just crushes
everybody right when he's like
yeah
Loki's gonna go it's just like can you
believe it 100 you believe like that
he's like I did a good job and like for
Kratos to ever think he could think that
yeah is almost impossible
and then that leads into him going to
see the the path on the back side of the
other mural I mean that was like for us
like the magic moment and you know I was
one of those where I think you know
Chris was like I got like two takes in
me because I'm gonna put everything into
this so make sure we get it now and he
just left it all out and hang out
because everybody gets it you see it in
his face you're just like is he gonna do
oh my God you know what I mean like he
just hangs in there for the moment he
just sits right on that edge but he's
got you right there with him yeah
incredible but there's like so many
different things that we don't have time
to touch on like the whole like uh
yomunganda stuff and and like the
seating of of different things than the
previous game but I think the question
we should probably end on is like how do
you feel now and that you you look
around and there's like people who won
you know there's a review scores that
are like very high but then there's
people like us who like found so much
emotional worth in it and like and like
narrative worth in it and like
people I've spoken to people who are
like I'm genuinely like growing as a
person playing some of these things when
I hear people say stuff like that like
it stopped and made me think then I feel
like we've done our job because we're
not intentionally setting out to do
those things we're putting them there
and if you're willing to go into that
suspension of disbelief in a place where
it'll open you up to freely think
then
that's the result and it's really
amazing but it's not like you must feel
this way like I never grow into thinking
a scene needs to do that because it's
it's manipulative and that's not what
we're trying to do we're trying to leave
it for you and if it connects because of
all the little pieces that have come
together
then we've we've Hit The Sweet Spot and
you know it sounds like you had a few of
those and sounds like you had a shoe and
I have a whole bunch
um but that's all we can ask for because
we're also here to entertain you know
people are putting down seventy dollars
or depending on what country and seventy
dollars plus it's like so we want you to
have a really good time but if you know
you can think about a couple things
there's some subtext in there that
clicks with you and makes you a better
person and awesome because video games
should be able to do that films TV movie
they all books they all do those things
why and why can't video games
[Music]
thank you
[Music]